parts of latin america are finding a new
normal amid the pandemic
but tragedy remains a reality for many
[Music]
brazil has seen the highest number of
coronavirus cases in the region
officials there say the virus is under
control and are even closing temporary
hospitals
like this one but more than 130 000
people have died during the pandemics so
far in brazil
why has it been a hotbed for the virus
the pandemic is also putting the squeeze
on latin american livelihoods
can governments help their citizens make
ends meet
and we begin with a look at brazil where
a lack of government response has
devastated the most vulnerable groups
in particular those living paycheck to
paycheck often
in the informal economy left to try and
fill in the gap
are community groups
people are angry angry about prison
bolsonaro's right-wing politics
about exclusion and racism about the
many covered 19
deaths and about the fact that nothing
is being done about it in this country
the protests are led by outro football
fans of the corinthian football club
[Music]
[Applause]
every saturday the fans cook meals to
help the poorest people
those who have been hit hard by the
pandemic today alone
they will distribute 1 000 meals on the
city streets
they deliver the food packages in their
private cars they head for the center of
sao paulo in a convoy
for these homeless people the free meal
is a blessing
with its rice pasta and sausage they
have only been homeless for a few weeks
they could no longer pay their rent due
to the coronavirus crisis
they are brazil's new poor
the government should come out of its
palaces and see with its own eyes what
is happening in this country
brazil's president bossonero who usually
appears without a mask
continues to downplay the coronavirus
risk
he has also been criticized for not
always publishing the number of victims
the number of unreported cases is
especially high in the favelas
so in rio de janeiro residents have
started their own count
many victims of the virus in our favela
weren't counted by the health
authorities we have a few examples of
that among our circle of friends
the volunteers talk to their neighbors
and note the cases
many are part of the unreported number
there are some coveted 19 cases here
some survive others don't
with the help of numerous favela
residents the volunteers compile their
own lists for their poor district of
burrell
they also collect data on sick people
via what's up
something the city council does not do
since the favelas appeared the
government is conspicuous in its absence
we always have to reinvent ourselves and
break new ground
as other football fans in sao paulo here
under a highway bridge at 10 pm
the altras go where hardly any others
would set foot
cars drive across the bridge above while
down below
families in need have built a place to
live
they too are among the pandemics new
poor
this family brought a kitchen cupboard a
bed and a stove from their rented
apartment just a few weeks ago
now they can only hope for better times
and that the outra's important help will
not stop
during the crisis i could no longer pay
my rent my wife and i became unemployed
we have three children
so our only option was to come here i
built this shelter myself
with poverty comes fear of the virus and
of being left behind
during the pandemic
[Music]
and i'm joined now by marika blowfield
she's director of the giga institute for
latin american studies in hamburg
which is where she's joining us for
america it's good to have you on the
show
the lack of government help for brazil's
poor during so much of this pandemic
has that been by design or by omission
well i mean actually the brazilian
government overall hasn't been
completely
unattentive to the needs of the poor
and that's been actually not by the
design of the executive government but
the opposition
back in late march so right after the
pandemic started
the opposition and civil society came
together and pushed through emergency
cash assistance
and the government did not veto it and
as a result
actually about one-third of the
brazilian population currently receives
emergency cash assistance
from the government which is the highest
level of any latin american country
however of course it doesn't meet
all basic needs while it's relatively
sufficient enough to buy
food it doesn't necessarily cover rents
and such and so still people for example
in sao paulo who lose their jobs are
still in dire economic straits
so there is a social protection floor in
brazil
but of course it doesn't mitigate all
the devastating effects of the economic
crisis and this has been pushed through
by the opposition rather than
the government why have we seen covet
really take off in latin america it
seems like in comparison to some other
regions
there was a bit more of a delay before
cases really took off
and still things have been pretty bad in
countries like brazil can we pin that on
any policies or on any
i don't know what do you see well i'm
not an epidemiologist but i can tell you
this
that part of i mean humans are vectors
of transmission and so social distancing
measures have really helped
to mitigate the spread of the virus
however if you implement social
distancing
you absolutely have to also especially
in poorer countries make sure the
families have the means
to feed themselves while they stay at
home and in countries that can't do that
you can't expect people to stay at home
and starve or watch their kids go hungry
and not go out on the streets
and try to make an income and so that's
one of the key challenges that latin
american countries as well as
all developing countries have had is how
to make sure that people can actually
adhere to the social distancing measures
and in a region with very high levels of
informality in the workforce about half
of the workforce is employed informally
and you know if they lose their jobs
from one day to the next that means
their
income disappears so you need to get
help to them very very fast and that was
a significant challenge in pretty much
every single latin american country
except uruguay
that had a strong social protection
system going into the crisis
perhaps more comparable to what you see
in germany
and they were able to get that
assistance to people fast but otherwise
it was a real challenge and that was one
of the factors that made it very hard to
tamp down on the
virus as well what do we see when we
look at these countries healthcare
systems as well we know that with
other regions that's also been a
challenge is dilapidated or
healthcare systems that haven't been
investment invested in rather
overall yes because one of the key
characteristics of latin america
is that tremendously high levels of
socioeconomic inequality and so you have
an underfunded public health sector that
serves the majority of the population
and then you have
a better resource private health care
sector however neither
were prepared to confront a pandemic of
this magnitude and now you see the
results
it was interesting in that piece seeing
how the community comes out on one hand
the football clubs on the other hand
some volunteers in the favelas
i'm guessing that might be nice but
perhaps not enough to really
make so much of a difference when you're
talking about a pandemic
that's correct i mean civil society help
is always
important but if you're dealing with a
shock such as a pandemic you absolutely
have to have a state that is prepared to
confront these kinds of social risks
and unfortunately most latin american
countries
the weak state capacity has come to the
fore with this crisis
and many governments are recognizing
that now and seeking to invest
more in it i want to ask you before we
go
about peru i believe it has the highest
mortality rate in the world from cove
but still
any reason for that well i think the
factors
uh that i mentioned uh peru
is a country with very high levels of
informality 80
of the workforce is informal and so when
the pandemic hit
they depended on the informal sector for
their income and
social distancing was quite brutal and
they couldn't sustain it
at the same time the government had a
really hard time reaching the entire
population
and still in august five months later
many people were still waiting for
for cash assistance help from the
government
so in those kinds of circumstances it's
very very hard to effectively implement
social distancing measures
add to that simply lots of people living
in pretty
bad housing conditions in urban slums
where social distancing is very
difficult
some people don't even have fridges so
they can't prepare for example meals for
an entire week they have to go out every
day and buy food
all right marika bloefield director of
the giga institute for latin american
studies in hamburg thank you very much
and now it's time for your questions to
our science correspondent derek williams
how long does an asymptomatic person or
one who has overcome covid19
remain a possible source of infection
regardless of whether you have symptoms
or if you're asymptomatic
if you've been diagnosed with covet 19
it's important
not to leave isolation until your local
health authority
says you no longer pose a danger to
others
in its recommended guidelines the who
says that on
average positive patients who show
symptoms
could be infectious for up to 10 days
after symptoms first appeared
it also says patients should wait at
least that long
plus three days after they're
symptom-free without any medication
so a person with an average case of
covet 19
if there is such a thing should isolate
a minimum
of 13 days for asymptomatic people
the who recommendation is to isolate for
at least 10 days
since your last positive test various
national health authorities have
interpreted those recommendations
in different ways there's no zero risk
scenario
but as a rule of thumb people who test
positive
whether they're they're symptomatic or
asymptomatic
are now viewed as being no longer
infectious
after two weeks
you